right now we turn our attention away
from
the seemingly perennial political issues
of the transgender agenda
the radical cultural agenda even the
great reset agenda
we turn now to a major news story that
is not getting nearly enough attention
in Ohio
this would be the train derailment that
sent a vinyl chloride and a number of
other very very dangerous chemicals up
into the atmosphere local officials
burned this stuff off it put phosphine
into the air that was poison gas from
World War One put hydrochloric acid into
the air it killed a lot of animals in
the town it caused an evacuation though
now the authorities are saying oh that's
okay it's not a big deal everything's
fine don't worry about your water don't
worry about your air quality come on
back here let's get those news cameras
out of Ohio and let's go back to normal
well if that's the case how come we
aren't hearing from people in the town
itself we will do that today with
Lindsay Johnston a 26 year old wife and
mother of two daughters who lives in the
one mile evacuation Zone in East
Palestine Ohio Lindsay very sorry what
happened to your town and thank you for
coming on the show
thank you for having me Michael so
Lindsay
before we get to the reaction
what happened as you and your neighbors
have seen it
um so my husband and I were actually we
were out of town just
um a few miles up north
um when it happened and when we're on
our way back we had a bunch of people
texting us you know are you guys okay
um what's going on up there
and we hadn't heard anything about it
yet
um
so we got we got home and we had been
like watching things on the news and we
just started packing immediately
um I don't think it was until
later that they came around they came
around with um speakers and their cars
saying you know you should evacuate but
at that point it wasn't mandatory yet
um but we did leave that night
um
so we've been in we've been out
for I think 12 13 days now
um
but I mean as of right now they say that
it is safe for us to return home
um they you know February 6th they were
saying that there was
um the wines words were we were facing
grave danger of death
um they were threatening child
endangerment charges to anybody that did
stay behind if they had children with
them and then two days later they said
it's absolutely safe to go home
how on Earth are they going to reconcile
those two statements I mean we we've
seen news reports that say oh there's no
big deal there's no health risk not even
to your animals we've we're testing the
air we're testing the water and then you
see the pictures in the videos of people
who who are looking at all of their
chickens lying dead whose animals have
died obviously there's poison everywhere
how is how is all that poison just
cleared out of town poison that could
have killed your children if you spent
the night there how could that possibly
clear out of town in 48 hours
right exactly those are exactly our
thoughts um we know that there are some
people that have returned
um and have gotten sick I know our
neighbors went home for a day and they
um
I think they and their one of their
children broke out in a rash had
scratchy throats I went back for just a
half an hour to get some stuff from our
house and I left with a scratchy throat
um my husband's been at our house a few
times to clean
um and he said that for the last three
days he's been having trouble breathing
um yeah it's I mean they've found at
least 3 500 dead fish in the streams
and I mean all the time on you know our
East Palestine Facebook groups and
things their people are posting pictures
of their animals and dead animals that
they find with no you know indication of
trauma or anything
um they're just dead with no explanation
how far out of town have you evacuated
um right now we are in Negley which is
just the next town over we're on the far
end of Negley with my mom
um we had been we'd been probably a half
an hour out of town before that um we
were in two separate hotels like going
from different places and stuff trying
to figure stuff out but
um I know this is you know for a lot of
people in town
it's hard to manage this it's hard to
afford nobody planned for this to have
to spend two weeks in a hotel room and
I'm sure plenty of people are also
thinking okay you go one town over you
go Two Towns over well we've just talked
about an historic chemical explosion
it's not as though yeah you know these
places are going to be unaffected as
well what are the authorities doing and
saying in town
um I mean
you know there was a there was a town
hall meeting last night
um
and
our mayor has said you know that he's
fed up as well
um but we're really not
seeing a lot happening
um
I I feel like we're not holding Norfolk
as accountable as we should be
um they rebuilt the railroad before the
evacuation was even lifted they rebuilt
it over contaminated soil
and
you know it's mostly the help is coming
from local organizations getting
together donating water or donating you
know things to people that need it
um sending food to the hotels where
there are a lot of residents
um but I mean
their official statements are it's safe
to return home the water is safe to
drink but I mean even Mike dewine said
that he would be drinking bottled water
um of course you know and he said that
he would return home but I think that he
would also have the financial ability to
get you know private testing done
instead of the testing that's being
contracted out by Norfolk Southern
this seems to be the biggest
environmental disaster on U.S soil in
probably in my lifetime I mean you think
about maybe 911 or you know a major
terror attack uh accepted in terms of
just an actual accident environmental
catastrophe you know clogging up the air
in the water I haven't seen anything
like it
where is the federal government I assume
Transportation secretary Pete Buda judge
hasn't come by I know that President
Biden hasn't have you seen anything from
the federal government
well our county is uh
uh in in the last election our County
voted 71 Republican so I uh I kind of
feel like maybe we're not that important
to the federal government
wow and especially with all the language
about the flyover country and the
deplorables and the irredeemables and
the let small town America die yeah it's
no surprise I'm not surprised that East
Palestine has been completely overlooked
by the Biden Administration by The
Establishment media by pretty much
everybody but
once this news story goes away as the
people who write our news are trying to
do more and more so by the hour you're
still going to have to live there this
is where your homes are that this this
Whole Town's going to have to live with
this and we can hear that the air is
safe and the water safe nobody actually
believes that you're telling me that
your neighbors and even your husband are
experiencing this is not safe they are
getting sick when they go back to clean
the home so it's obviously just a
complete Croc that's coming from the
authorities and it's going to go on for
years and so what's going to happen you
live in this town for five years 10
years 20 years
what what consequences are you going to
have to deal with that the railroad
isn't going to have to deal with that
the government's not going to have to
deal with that everybody is just going
to look past it's a really really awful
situation I guess the the only thing we
can do is call some attention to it and
demand that the government do a damn
thing about it
yeah yeah
um I mean we're all concerned of what
you know what health issues we might all
experience down the line and I mean our
home values who who's gonna buy who if
we decide to move away right what are we
going to do who's going to buy
um you know it's people can't
if they're homeowners they can't just up
and leave if you rent it might be a
little bit easier for you but you know
we own our home and so what are we
supposed to do how are we supposed to
you know avoid this when we don't know
what's going to happen in the future and
we don't believe what they're telling us
right and and rightly so you there's no
reason that you should believe what
they're telling you in fact your own
experience is proving that what they're
saying is not true Lindsay we'll have to
leave it there you will be in our
prayers as will everybody in East
Palestine and I hope that there is a
little more political help that comes
your way uh from the people who are who
are absolutely overlooking you and the
rest of the people in your community
right now uh Lindsey Johnson thanks so
much for coming on the show thank you go
to dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you